hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina we're to bring you a
review of probably one of the most
anticipated games of early 2014 and will
be 14 the show and well before wait oh
yeah well no no good game coming out
this is our titanfall review it's only
off for xbox one now sorry for those of
you who only have xbox 360's you have to
wait another two weeks believe it's
april eighth now in the US april
eleventh and europe so sorry for the
wait but mike and i got to put on the
xbox one play a little titanfall respawn
is this a call of duty killer first
impressions I mean it's wolf again you
never want to compare right franchise
never fear yes sir oh it definitely has
the potential obviously Call of Duty has
you know this track Greg it's been
around for years as a track record of
being this like I don't want to say
hardcore you know first person the
battlefield fans like that's the heart
exact other game called our mother blast
Maria there's like the words like we
know real what you know ya know you did
right yeah but it's good and I saw this
before i'm a call of duty fan and I do
like it I feel like as this is their
first outing new franchise it definitely
has the potential it just has a few
kinks that I think they need to work out
right and I think for the game for
coming out i think did a good job it was
it looks good it runs smooth I think
they just want to get the game I know
there's a lot of stuff coming with the
new patches that's got a great dlc map
pack for like 25 bucks for me three
packs that's pretty cheap considering
like the 60 fifty dollars that you pay
for call of duty and I like the gameplay
for me because I made out of Call of
Duty for the last few so used to be in a
few years ago and I've been getting out
what like about this game is you don't
have to be good at first person shooters
to be good at this game I know this is
Mike and I were playing I we would be
first second place but we might maybe
get five six kills against regular guys
and maybe died 15 20 times but because
there's so many points you can get from
assisting your friends that you're
playing with using your titans you can
still get a lot of experience in XP
points it's not about your kill death
ratio which there was a turnoff for some
people because it feels like me to play
call do you just die every time that's
not anymore and one of things i like
about this game is that you're always
moving you have to move one of things i
hate about you can't but there's not
it's not as big of an issue that I've
noticed
farplane exactly it's not what I've seen
I know like you have you played with the
actual full version again a lot longer
than I have but from what I've seen so
far as far as like camping is concerned
I feel like it's almost non-existent
compared to like a call of duty or
something we're just people just play
whole matches camping or like that so I
like that it's like it forces you to
move which is a good thing yeah I love
the the patient again i love the maps
there's some really cool math was I was
really mad they're big beautiful big
enough so they kind of need to be big
because of the the mechs because of the
titans you know they are big thing up a
lot of sisters your scope of something
yeah there's that one I can't read what
it's called with that the big auto
dinosaur big dinosaurs there's a day map
in a nightmare yeah there's a 12 with
dragons mm-hmm I love that one that's
like there's like these dragons at
flower on like if you wait too long in
one air they might pick you up and throw
you somewhere so the map design is great
I which was a little bit more variety in
guns there's this a good amount of guns
but you do have to level up to earn them
as a call duty you know player to I love
black ops you can just kind of save up
money and buy certain guns but like i
said it's fair you and i played mostly
hard point i'm not a big team deathmatch
which they call a attrition yeah so he
played what they call hard point which
is like domination where you capture you
know a B and C and hold a flag I like
the team base yeah more because instead
of you know lone wolf stuff yeah village
there aren't that many game modes
another calming ice but it's just yeah
they got like maybe six it would have
been nice if they could have already
just included a few more right right
again that's that's nitpicking because
the game still is fun yes well yeah it's
just a few more game modes would have
been nice right too bad because i think
you know you'll talk about this is that
xbox is only moved i mean i don't know
the exact numbers now but i know it's
over three million me they're
approaching four million units now you
think about in the world scope of the
world that's not that many people
compared to how people have xbox 360's
and they're still delayed on the 360
really spend a lot of you out there have
360 s and it sucks as you still have to
wait another couple weeks to play it and
I wish say they need to kind of get on
that but at least this game is good run
smooth not a lot of bugs servers not
like the battlefield fiasco with EA this
year the servers work well so yeah it
runs well which is which is good for any
game I know you and I talked about the
campaign yeah now that's
kind of i think the achilles heel right
for this game now i know they didn't
want it let's face it like games like
Call of Duty for example campaigns are
just like whatever you play them or you
don't I mean I I usually play a campaign
and call of duty maybe once or twice and
that's it I never touch it again and so
I understand that and that's smart for
for them to have not put so much of a
focus on this just and try to do
something different and I appreciate
creativity and they tried to include
make it online and include some of these
online modes but while playing the game
it's hard I know you'd said it's too
yeah focus on the store exactly
especially like you know you're playing
you'll see you know a screen over here
these guys and girls talking to you
about what's going on they'll be like
you know I got to take down this ship
over here i'm in the the turret you know
it's like you just can't pay attention
it's on your time so a little would be a
guy talking to you in the plane or in
the ship before about to drop down and
you're basically just playing either
team deathmatch attrition or you're
playing hard point domination with a
story going on in the background but
yeah so chaotic which i love about the
game yeah but doesn't give time to focus
on a kind of that story if you're
playing multiplayer and stuff and that's
this is definitely one of the Kings that
they need to work out you play multiple
you're focusing on the game right yeah
you know what I mean you're so much good
make sure somebody's gonna light you up
you know what I mean try to focus on
that and have like just something it up
in the right-hand corner of your screen
trying to tell you story it's kind of
hard because like you said we did our
bader if you you appreciate it that
makes you feel like you're in a war
absolutely this game makes you flick
universe when there's like somebody
talking over your ear and I even when
sometimes where am I you know I gave
some like you know nice headphones I
wear like when I'm listening just like I
like hear all the audio like I still
can't hear everything it's just too much
noise yeah so that's the one thing I
know it wasn't a shock they didn't
promise us an in-depth single-player
campaign it said it's going to move
along with the multiplayer so at least
we weren't shocked but at the same time
it's a little bit of a deterrence at
least call of duty their stories aren't
great but they do try to tell a story
halo definitely tells the story other
first-person shooters Bioshock tells the
story I wish we could have gotten a
little more story not like a big huge
campus a little more store because the
world that they've created looks frickin
awesome I guys like you see dragons
these monsters are too big like sorry
like brontosaurus looking dress of Clark
you know things I I want to go out there
and see what that looks like but you
can't really explore beyond the math you
can find to yeah it'd be it'd be kind of
cool if they may be add
something to the campaign in the dlc
right I doubt that sprite you later but
I'm like that but it'd be nice maybe in
the future we might you know and that's
what I meant like I just think that
there's definitely the potentials there
I think maybe with the sequel whenever
that comes up is you know it's bound it
happened we're gonna get a sequel to
titanfall they can definitely learn from
some of these mistakes and put out a
better game right so let's move on to I
guess our decisions are verdicts you
know think hero heroes you do you know
an f2 a you know an A+ in terms of our
ratings also to just saw you like you
know for those of you don't have xbox
one's is this worth do you think in your
opinion getting Xbox one over and what's
your grade for the game that you would
give it um well it's I definitely don't
think it's worth running out and buying
an xbox one right now for now of course
if you want to get yourself an xbox one
to get the titanfall bundle there's also
some a game on Amazon yeah they're still
there yes 60 bucks off rightly so it's
like yeah in that case do it but if
you're still if you have a 360 you're
still on the fence should I get one now
I'd say wait it out um wait for destiny
yeah I know what I mean I think that
would be probably the first thing i do
like yeah exercise for go get an xbox
one or that but this game is definitely
worth buying fueling 360 wait for the
360 version well I think this game is
good the second game might be better but
if I had to grade it i would say again
based off like what I've seen so far
like where they can go I'd say it's
still a solid B I had a lot of fun game
you know it wasn't perfect it had a few
rough edges but a good solid B is
definitely worth playing Stefan it's
worth owning for air I would go as the
one level higher go a B+ is because I
really enjoyed the multiplayer
experience I liked not having to get a
lot of kills to get points and it's kind
of pulled me back into play multi like
I'm already at level 40 which isn't much
some people are like a prestige for one
guy already maxed out less than a week
how do I mean do have jobs paying the
bills thank you for the lights on in the
house maybe the little kids and the mom
does all that no dad yes um yeah i'll
give it a B+ i would enjoy say you could
get on your 360 sorry have to wait a
little while pc gamers you know it's
already out so you can pick that up now
this looks good on 36 it does look at on
360 we played that on the bait on PC
Ethel yeah just as I mean xbox one looks
good but i thought pc look great too so
you know those are our thoughts on
titanfall you know the console
generation the new next-gen is here
nextgen you know I'm when are you going
to get a ps4 when you get an xbox one we
got destiny we got watchdogs coming out
if you're an infamous fan on PS you know
ps4 got infamous second son coming out
so all this great stuff in the world of
video games let us know you think you
can find us always think eurocom we're
also in this YouTube page here think
hero pro makes you give us a like
subscribe to that we're also on Twitter
dr. dennis michael and myself for all
game or as well have systems tell us
what your favorite games are that's um
at think here i'm at griffin de i'm at
mr. Michael Alexis we also the facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
your fans make sure you spread the word
social media is out there use it you
know talk about all things to your TV
shows video games movies yeah we'll talk
to you soon